here now johnny joey jones retired
marine bomb technician and fox news
contributor so you heard the president
said he would hunt these guys down
i don't know were you buying that
uh the only courageous or honest thing
that joe biden did today was he took a
question from peter ducey i appreciate
that
or a matter of fact all week long and
you know it'd be easy to sit up here and
just go after him and i want to trust me
i do because it got real today i mean
you're talking about you know 12 marines
and another marine when you're talking
about a navy corpsman that's a marine i
mean we feel that way about them they
earned the title for the navy and i
appreciate that but we we consider them
one of ours and so that's a navy
corpsman not a medic um and that's
important
all right they're dead today i know what
it's like to be on that battlefield
bleeding out without the help of your
friends you're gonna die
um
the least you can do is know why you're
dying know why you're put in that
situation you know that's the least you
can do for these men and women i i i'm
disgusted and this is not about partisan
politics for all i know 12 democrats
could have done better and maybe trump
would have done worse but you know who
the president is the president's joe
biden the same dude that was vice
president when they sent me in 39 999
others to win the 2012 election not the
afghan war in 2010. this is very
personal for me and i think the one
thing i want to point out people
understand why did 13 service members
die and why does that not happen very
often because when we're on the
offensive when we're fighting a war when
we're doing what we know we have
disbursement we have formations we have
tactics and procedures we're not meant
to be tsa we're not meant to cattle
guard in a visible choke point and to
help kids get food and water and to pick
them up over walls that's not our job
and we shouldn't be put in that
situation these men never had a chance
because they were doing something
they're not trained and supposed to be
doing because the entire situation isn't
supposed to happen and you can't lie to
me convincingly enough that there was no
other way to do it no they're doing
paperwork now they're looking at papers
they're pulling babies across the wire
and they're not on offense now when you
saw the news about these dead marines
today
you want to go on offense you want to
push the perimeter back because i would
say if i was the commander-in-chief of
the taliban you screwed up
you blew the deal you were supposed to
provide security you didn't do it so now
we're providing security we should be
manning checkpoints the taliban should
not be manning checkpoints because
that's what happened when that happens
we're in a full retreat in desperation
that's that's the battle terminology
that's where we are we're in a full
retreat um and if that's the case get
the hell out of there
right now he's going to this moment he's
going to take my brothers and sisters
out of there and then maybe contractors
will go over there and do your job joe
biden maybe they'll go save the
americans that need to be saved because
my
fellow service members aren't going to
be able to do it that's obvious this
over the horizon capability you couldn't
go over the mountain range and find
osama bin laden for 20 years i'm sorry
but what is over the horizon capability
you don't know what's happening in
pakistan when you're in afghanistan
that's that's
that's just a military phrase he heard
in the situation room and he's repeating
it to sound smart you know what the deal
is with him that's just how it is what
i'm afraid of is that as we're leaving
on these aircraft the last guys out
there shooting at us as we leave as as
we're taking off the tarmac
rpgs howitzers well where did they come
from
us yeah and that's a disgrace johnny
joey jones thank you so much thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else